طالبان يبدو حلف ما توقفتهلنا وهذه الايام
جالسه بتحتفل بانجاز شايفين التاريخي وحدث
مهم جدا والمتحدث باسم الحركات ذبيحه الله
مجاهد هو اللي ضيف او اللي زاف لنا الخبر
الرهيب ونشر الفيديو على حسابه على تويتر
واكتفى بكم كلمه كابشن فقال سياره صنعت في
افغانستان
[موسيقى]
اديني شفت المونتاج والاضاءه والتفحيط في
الاستعراض يعني طلبان يعني تعبانه يعني في
المقطع اللي بتتباها فيه باول سياره من
صنعها
لكن الحقيقه انه الانجاز وهمي وبس وهمي لا
والله انجاز مضحك كمان يعني فالسياره اللي
اسمها ماده تسعه وطالبان بتقول لنا اول
سوبر سياره افغانستان افغانيه وانه اشتغل
عليها 30 مهندس على مدى خمس سنين هي في
الحقيقه لا سياره سوبر ولا شيء بسياره
محطوط فيها محرك تويوتا كورولا حتى تويوتا
كورولا موديل السنه لا تويوتا موديل 2000
مو بس كده طالبان ما كشفت اي مواصفات
للسياره حتى ما قالت السياره دفع امامي
ولا خلفي يعني وما في اي سوره حتى للسياره
من جوه طبعا رئيس الهيئه المصنعه للسياره
قال انه السياره تبدا من سيارتها من
افغانستان ويعمل
توصل للعالم ما اعتقد هتوصل لاي مكان يعني
على فكره وقال كمان انهموه للبيع حتى الان
مع انه جاتهم طلبات عده لشراءهم
[موسيقى]